В принципі, в рукавицях також все видно.
Де тут?
Ось, ще трішечки ближче.
Я його бачила мільйон разів.
Макет, з якого все почалося.
Так!
І Львівська міська ратуша.
Я є скульптором, якщо порахувати, вже,
навіть не в третьому, а в четвертому поколінні.
Мій прадід, Павло, був народним майстром
і працював, різьбив по дереву.
Десь енну кількість років тому,
ми тут робили постать Шевченка.
Для Севастополя.
І цей пам'ятник тепер там стоїть, в Севастополі.
Це власне фотографія, де ми втрьох,
з батьком і дідом, створювали пам’ятник Шевченку.
[сміється]
Я тоді ще символічно долучався
до цього процесу, але вийшло так.
Звичайно, батько з дідом працювали найбільше.
Це одна з найкращих фотографій, де ми втрьох.
Дуже важливо, що це абсолютно його самостійне рішення.
Я, як з Василем, так і зі своїми
молодшими колегами-студентами,
ніколи не намагаюся нав’язати їм свою думку.
Треба лише створити відповідну атмосферу
і можливість для розвитку.
Я намагаюсь ставити їм великі проблеми.
Великі питання.
Тоді вже намагаємося разом знайти методи
і способи шляху до [їх вирішення].
Я дуже люблю Львівську академію мистецтв.
Це мій дім.
Я там вчився і зараз я маю нагоду там ділитись
своїм досвідом з молодими митцями.
Звичайно, скажу щиро, це не було моїм
пріоритетом стати викладачем.
І сподіваюся, що більшість студентів
не вважають мене викладачем.
[сміється]
Так як і я, не вважаю їх своїми студентами.
Ми — творчі особистості.
Костя, ти ще досі не доліпив пальчики?
Коли ти вже мав доліпити пальці?
Подивися, ще сира ліва стопа.
Ось.
По очах можна ще пройтися.
Скульптура — це, перш за все, ремесло.
[сміється]
Робота з матеріалами, інструментами.
Але кожен прагне, щоб ремесло стало високим.
Так може вийде і мистецтво.
Це Львівська опера.
Власне, вона була побудована у 1900 році.
У стилі неоренесансу і необароко.
Ми відтворили абсолютно точну копію цієї опери,
щоб можна було, власне, торкаючись
пізнати всі елементи архітектури.
— Дуже деталізовано!
— Навіть вікна є.
— Так.
— Так, всі вікна є! Кожне вікно є!
[сміється]
Мені здається, що ми зараз живемо в такий момент,
коли будь-який живий контакт:
зоровий,  фізичний — він колосально цінується
і є набагато більшим, ніж раніше.
Хто, рік тому міг подумати, що наш світ,
не лише місто чи країна, а весь світ,
в одну секунду так зміниться.
Ми всі і кожен з нас раптово ізолювався.
Ми були поставлені в такі умови.
Певною мірою це співвідноситься
з тими обмеженнями і ізоляцією,
в якій постійно перебувають незрячі.
Які не бачать навколишнього світу
і повністю занурені в себе і свою уяву.
Єдиним джерелом інформації,
з якого вони можуть почерпнути інформацію про світ,
є звук і дотик.
Я, як людина, яка до 24-х років бачила,
а тепер втратила зір...
За ці, більше ніж 20 останніх років, почала забувати,
як все виглядає, як виглядає місто.
Тобто, коли мене хтось запитає, де знаходиться
міська ратуша, я скажу як туди пройти.
Але коли мене попросять її описати,
то я не зможу її описати.
Я пам’ятаю, коли ми відкривали макет ратуші у 2016 році.
Це був перший макет у Львові.
Я не очікував, по-перше, що буде так багато людей
і, найголовніше, дітей було дуже багато.
Багато дітей, які не можуть бачити так,
як ми це бачимо.
Я дивився, як вони із захопленням
мацають цей макет з усіх сторін.
Я це ніколи не забуду.
— Зараз знімлю рукавиці і прочитаю.
— Але треба дуже швидко читати, щоб не замерзнути.
Я бачу!
Львівський національний театр опери та балету.
Так, ми тут написали українською мовою,
англійською і шрифтом Брайля.
Один і той самий текст.
Я собі часом думаю, як це, не бачити
і вперше пізнати, в якому місті ти живеш.
Якою є основна будівля — Львівської міської ради.
Який є Оперний львівський, один із найвідоміших в Європі.
Це колосальні відчуття.
І я щасливий, що маю можливість долучитися до цієї справи.
Тому що, я відчуваю, що, по-перше, ти потрібен.
І ти робиш невеликі кроки покращення того простору,
в якому ти народився і в якому ти живеш.
І в якому я планую жити.
Є зір, але ти не помічаєш довкола
себе дуже багато речей.
Ти не звертаєш на них увагу, тому що, знаєте,
люди зрячі не цінують те,
що вони мають, на превеликий жаль.
Ми, ті, хто втратив зір, ми починаємо
розуміти, що ми втратили.
Якби я, наприклад, колись знала, що я осліпну,
то я б просто дивилася на все.
Щоб, знаєте, забити собі в пам’ять всю ту красу
України, Львова, яка є навколо нас.
Якби мене запиталися одним словом, що для мене...
Що мені дає ось цей макет, так?
І Львівської опери, і решта макетів,
які ви, Василь, зробили.
Одним словом, я б сказала просто:
дякую, але я бачу.